a standalone dedicated Quidditch game is
coming but there's something the devs
absolutely have to change something that
could really make or break the success
of this game and how many players will
be interested in actively playing but
what's this problem I'm talking about
well it's actually a problem with
quidditch itself at least how it's
written in the books anyway and how
exactly that would translate to a video
game if you think about the movies
quidditch isn't really a significant
enough plot point there for most to even
notice this but the rules in the books
are actually kind of head scratching
quidditch as it's written in the books
is a completely untimed sport the game
only ends when the golden snitch is
caught of course each team has one
player taking the role of Seeker which
is the only position allowed to catch
the snitch oh and there's also the fact
that it's worth an extra 150 points to
the team that catches it so the
situation we have here is that most of
the action in quidditch is centered
around the other positions with each
team having three Chasers two beaters
and one keeper even if you look back to
Harry Potter Quidditch World Cup in 2003
which was a dedicated game specifically
for quit most of the action was all
about the Chasers you have so much
action and attention focused on these
positions And yet when the Chasers do
manage to score a goal past the other
team's keeper it's worth only 10 points
so in the vast majority of quidditch
games the team whose Seeker catches the
snitch is highly likely to be the
winning team even if the other six
positions were significantly outplayed
and because it's the physical act of
catching the snitch that wins a game if
the Seeker finds his or her team down
more than 150 points there'd be almost
no reason to catch the snitch even
though that's exactly what Victor Crumb
did in book 4. but for a competitive
video game that just won't fly now
quidditch roll cup had to change this up
already and as I already mentioned in
that game you primarily play as the
Chasers now as you complete certain
passes do Combos and score goals the
meter in the center of the screen here
will get closer and closer to the snitch
so it's actually rewarding the team
that's doing better quidditch roll cup
also makes it so the overall rankings
are based on points not wins and losses
so even if your team is down by more
than 150 points you still have at least
some incentive to catch the snake image
because that's going to give you 150
points in the standings unfortunately in
crumbs situation this was the final game
of the season and didn't really matter
so you can start to see the problem here
as we talk about an online competitive
Quidditch game with players having the
opportunity to play each of quidditch's
positions and it's already been pretty
much confirmed that all seven positions
are in the game the position of the
Seeker how games end and how many points
are awarded from the snitch creates a
few different problems for a video game
version of the iconic Wizarding World
sport that won't be easy to solve all of
these problems really center around you
the player and keeping things
challenging but most importantly keeping
them fun because for any multiplayer
focused game to succeed the number one
component needed is a strong consistent
player base so the first problem with
the Canon rules for quidditch is match
length the books even poke fun at the
fact that games can quite literally end
in seconds or even go on for days so for
a video game that is multiplayer and
needs an active number of players to
succeed it's important for game link to
be at least somewhat predictable so
there's a realistic expectation on how
long each game will take if game games
are too long you risk players leaving in
the middle of a match if they're too
short you could have games that don't
feel challenging and rewarding you also
have to factor in queue times that are
inevitable for any multiplayer game in
between matches if the games themselves
take too long to finish this could
result in even longer wait times for
those trying to queue into a new match
but to be fair that would be an issue no
matter what if there's a small player
base so again it's incredibly important
to have a healthy base of players on and
active most of the time the second issue
we have here is the vast Point disparity
between the catching of the snitch and
the scoring of goals with the quaffle
we're talking a 140 Point difference
here and I struggle to think of any real
world sport examples that we can compare
to this I mean just imagine if you're
playing the role of online Quidditch
game you block every shot that comes
your way your Chasers do well and score
140 points but then the other team
Seeker swoops in and catches the snitch
to secure the victory you essentially
had zero outcome on the final result of
the match and then there's the actual
gameplay side of being a Seeker which
would be incredibly difficult to balance
I mean the way it's written in the books
there are times where Harry's just kind
of sitting there looking around round
trying to find a small little glimpse of
gold in the corner of his eye so the act
of catching the snitch would need to be
hard enough to prevent games from ending
quickly but not so hard that games go on
for too long so how do you do that and
also keep those playing the position
engaged and interested for the rest of
the match think about this guys if the
seeker's only job is to catch the snitch
and that's what ends the game we would
likely see players become so skilled
that online games would end very quickly
with the vast majority of players
feeling like they did nothing to
contribute to the end result so how do
the devs at unbroken Studios balance all
of this how do they balance the Canon
and what we all love about the sport but
also make it so that each position feels
valuable and fun to play and also
competitive let's take a look at three
possible solutions option one is to
actually keep the rules as close as
possible to the book version but place
an overall time limit on the game now if
the snitch isn't caught by that point
the game ends and the team with the most
points wins with this option you'd
really have to make sure that non-seeker
players felt their contributions were
actually worthwhile you could do this
through in-game experience points based
on player performance you could even do
something like quidditch World Cup where
your team actually earns points in the
standings so you could move up there
even if you technically lost the match
but again are we actually going to be
having consistent teams on this I don't
think so as far as how the experience
would work let's say you're playing
Chaser and your team loses but you
personally still scored five goals on
your own you'd be rewarded for that in
the form of XP which would maybe Grant
you access to in-game Rewards or
cosmetic items but you would definitely
need to have that incentive that even if
you lose the game there's still a reason
for you to go all out when you're
playing as Chaser beater or keeper
personally I don't love this option so
let's take a look at the next one and
this would be to use rules similar to
those created by the international
quidditch Association yeah if you didn't
know quidditch or quad ball as it's
called now is actually a sport we
Muggles play in the real world minus the
hole flying in the air bit now their
Rules start with what's in the source
material but they have a few key
modifications to not only make the sport
work in the real world to also deal with
the issues that we outlined before and
again it all starts with the Seeker so
under the the iqa rule Seekers actually
don't start the game on the pitch
instead they interplay after 18 minutes
of game time catching the snitch is also
worth just 30 points instead of 150. now
if the team that catches the snitch is
leading after the 30 points are awarded
that team wins and the game is over
however if the catching team is behind
after the 30 points are awarded the game
proceeds to an overtime period so in the
overtime it actually removes both The
Seekers and the snitch oh and by the way
in this version of quidditch the snitch
is actually a person who runs around
with snitch tag velcroed to the back of
their shorts again not kidding alright
with the snitch and both Seekers removed
from play a Target score is calculated
by taking the non-snitch catching teams
total and adding 30 points to it alright
let's have a little Hogwarts example
here to help us out let's say Gryffindor
is leading Slytherin by a score of 50 to
zero Slytherin then catches this Niche
giving them 30 points our new score is
Gryffindor 50 and Slytherin 30. we would
then proceed to that overtime period but
we need to calculate that Target score
so the officials with take Gryffindor
score of 50 and they would add 30 to it
which means the target score for both
teams is now 80 points score Remains the
Same overtime period begins and then
both teams are attempting to reach that
Target score in order to win no Seekers
though on the playing field now in my
opinion this would bring even more
issues into a video game version of
quidditch because if you think about it
it really significantly reduces the role
of Seeker where you would actually want
to play that position especially if
you're not even going to be out on the
field for part of the game so finally
we're left with what I think is the best
solution and it's sort of a combination
between the first two I think you would
have to start by having time periods or
maybe quarters but also lower the points
awarded when the snitch is caught now
here's the big difference rather than
ending the game when the snitch is
caught it basically just acts like any
other goal you stop play for a minute
get all the teams back in the starting
position and then you go again The
Seekers can catch the snitch again and
again and again for I don't know maybe
25 30 50 points this is really where
these play tests could come in handy
because they're going to be able to
figure out exactly how these games play
now I think this would keep Seekers
engaged for the whole game and also
would minimize their role because it
would allow for multiple catches of the
snitch it would also still help teams
catch up quickly if they had a top-notch
Seeker who could score multiple catches
of this niche in quick succession and at
the same time the Chasers beaters and
Keepers all of a sudden those positions
are on much more equal footing with the
seeker and are actually making
worthwhile contributions to the match
that affect the outcome but what do you
guys think let me know in the comments
below and check out the video on the
right side of your screen for the good
news and bad news related to those
ongoing play tests as always guys thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon